hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to my channel my name is Mai you go and
today we're gonna be talking about how
to start coding this is probably by far
the most common question that I get so
I'm excited to dive into this today so
my secret code Oh get it code because
we're talking about code on how to start
coding is to just do it and by that I
really mean build something for yourself
with code and don't focus too much on
specific technologies now I know it
sounds a little bit too simple or too
easy give that piece of advice but I
really think it's true coding is a skill
just like everything else so in order to
obtain and master a skill you have to do
it a lot Malcolm Gladwell famously
popularized that it takes about 10,000
hours to master a skill you know I'm not
telling anybody to spend 10,000 hours on
anything I think the essence of it is
true that you have to spend a lot of
time doing it because a practice makes
perfect right oh no that is not the case
in my high school orchids teacher would
tell you that it's perfect practice
makes perfect what she meant by that is
that it's not quantity but quality that
ultimately makes a huge difference in
how skilled you'll be at that thing take
you from my high scores to teacher
because violin is one heck of a hard and
trim it to learn so you could spend
10,000 hours doing every tutorial out
there on JavaScript and you could spend
10,000 hours doing problems on leaked
code but that's not going to get you
where you want to be nor is it a great
place to start because learning
technology for the sake of learning
technology is a tough road to walk down
especially for beginners for one thing
that you could get stuck in tutorial
land and by that I mean you're
completely relying on tutorials for
learning new tech there definitely is a
place for tutorials I'm not trying to
undermine them they're usually a great
way to get your feet wet in new
technology the best is when you can take
things from a tutorial and apply them to
your own stuff without that crucial
connection those newfound skills aren't
flexed and therefore not retained
and you just did a tutorial just to do
one so you'll be stuck in tutorial lands
but the other thing is that it's really
hard to stay motivated when you're
learning a new technology just to learn
it honestly this is really just a
personal opinion but I don't think that
technical documentation is necessarily
the most spiciest most dramatic and most
invigorating thing that I've ever read
quite frankly it's boring and it's
supposed to be the whole point of it is
that it's informational but if you're
not using any of the information then
why put yourself through that anyway I
digress that's just my own opinion and
the last reason for why it's difficult
to learn text just for the sake of it is
because that's not why it exists tech
helps solve problems that we have and
provides new solutions and the best way
to learn how to code is to do just that
learn by doing and build something cool
for yourself I do want to point out
though that technology based learning is
different from developing your coding
foundations learning the fundamentals of
coding allow you to gain a certain level
of fluency so that you can build
whatever you want and learn what you
need to you to build the thing and I'm
talking about like real basics here like
when you're learning the English
language you have to learn that alphabet
first before you can move on to any
words what I recommend is to first learn
how to think logically followed by data
structures and basic algorithms all of
which are offered on brilliant org who
is the sponsor of this video their
website that has a bunch of courses on
the sciences all the courses have
beautiful illustrations and are all
interactive which as a visual learner I
really appreciate what I love about the
brilliant courses is that they're all
easy to understand and they all teach
you how to think honestly I wish a lot
of my undergrad CS classes taught all of
this stuff as well as they do so go to
brilliant org slash hello may you go to
sign up for free and the first 200
people get 20% off of the annual premium
subscription the link is also in the
description box down below and brilliant
org thank you for sponsoring so when it
comes to learning
code build something for yourself
website and app what have you that you
would actually use for example a
shopping list app the helps you track
all the things they have to buy another
example a desktop app that helps you
track your ranking within a game so you
can see whether you're improving or not
or my last example a website that tells
you if Mercury's in retrograde this
whole method is actually called
project-based learning which is a term
that a lot of academics and education
use to describe the method of learning
something through solving a real-world
problem and through research in the last
20 years it's proven to be a great way
to learn especially in computer science
and software engineering and this is for
a couple of reasons the first is that
working on projects is inherently more
motivating than learning theoretical
concepts on their own the second is that
you tend to learn more than one skill
because you're solving a problem from
end to end and the last is that it
enhances collaboration and communication
skills because you're most likely gonna
be working on that project with someone
else or at least asking for help so
hopefully by now you understand the
value of project-based learning as a way
to how to start coding and I have a
couple of tips for you before you all
embark on your coding journeys the first
is to keep the project very very small
and this is because if you commit to a
very large project that takes a lot of
time that requires lots of new skills
it's really easy to lose motivation and
lose sight of why you're doing this in
the first place so start with like the
smallest possible chunk of the thing
that you can make you can always build
on top of this and just having small
goals means that they're way more
achievable and it'll be more fun the
second is to build something again for
yourself or for someone that you know
this part is actually really important
because it ties into the motivation
piece but building something for you or
for someone else means that you're
actually gonna care about this thing
also by knowing your knees or friends
means really well you're going to be
able to make decisions way quicker and
not get blocked and stay mode
and the last piece of advice is to work
on it with other people if you can work
on the project itself with another
person that's great
two heads are better than one if one of
you gets blocked you can help unblock
each other and help solve those problems
together also learning is more fun with
friends and maybe you want to fly solo
but find someone who can at least hold
you accountable for what you're gonna
make so ask your friend to check in like
once a week on how things are going
because that accountability can serve as
a really good motivator and these are
all of the reasons why I think building
something is the best way to get started
on coding anyway I hope you like this
video actually my husband Scott and I
have been working on a coding event for
the month of May where we are going to
bring together a community of people who
are all going to work on our personal
projects together this is not really
like a hackathon it's really not intense
at all it's just for fun and just for
working on it with other people with the
support of others and stuff it's gonna
be a fun time there's details in the
description box down below and pin as a
comment and don't forget to hit
subscribe I'm making a lot more videos
now so you don't want to miss out on
those so hit the subscribe button and I
will see you all next time hope you have
a great day wherever you are
bye